there is new fallout tonight after the
shake-up on TV's Dance Moms Abby Lee
Miller out former Dancing with the Stars
pro shell burst in and the kids are the
ones caught in the middle so what if the
parents think about the sudden switch
direction sources tell et that during
filming of the current season the Dance
Moms made a pact never to lead their
girls alone with Abby Lee one source
claims quote she's a bomb waiting to go
off and that the moms didn't feel their
children were safe around her meanwhile
Sheryl was all smiles yesterday outside
a new studio space where she worked with
the young dancers for the first time I'm
teaching very very talented kids and
very passionate mother
Cheryl's replacing Abby Lee for the
remaining four new episodes of the show
I was that kid and I had that type of
mom you know that was very passionate
about my career and very supportive Abby
Lee who quit the show via Instagram on
Sunday night told me she's done with the
producers of the show but wants the
girls to know that despite whatever
they've been told she's never been upset
with them and the girls are out there
they're on social media saying that I
said I don't want to work with them
that's bull this I never said that
you